hey everyone welcome to my first cheeky  short  so one question that often comes up is  what's the difference between calcium  alpha-ketoglutarate  and arginine alpha-ketoglutarate and  well the key difference is whether or  not it's got calcium or arginine now in  a study that came out in 2020 it was  shown that the calcium salt version of  akg extended both the health span and  lifespan of mice so this wasn't the  arginine version arginine in fact is an  amino acid so that could have  alternative implications and does not  guarantee that it would have the same  impact as was seen in this mile study  using calcium akg  but is calcium the sole reason or is it  the akg well i interviewed professor  brian kennedy who was one of the authors  on the study and they don't think it's  the calcium they think it's the akg